[Music]
yo what's up it's polo g
and you're watching on the rocks
this piece i got from icebox one of the
top jewelers
that i rock with i was supposed to have
got it by
may from my album that i had dropped
last year called the goat
but it's like they had a lot of things
they was backed up on orders from coving
and i had to wait a little time for it
but when i got it i was really excited
about it because
it was just something like i never had
before i'm just used to getting so much
more simple but this got a lot of
diamonds in it
and i feel like this is by far one of my
hardest custom pieces
it was a controversial piece too for
sure yeah everybody thinking i'm an
illuminati
i seen this chain in style when i was in
dubai and i had sent them a picture of
it like i wanted to change
this style when i was in a mall in dubai
you know they got like the jewelry
stores
inside the mall they got rich and really
stores inside them all so i was just
browsing around going from dreary store
to jersey store and i seen the chain
that was made that style and i told them
that's how i want the necklace to be
i came up with the idea of putting the
goats inside of the necklace
powder but they came up with a
detachable head in the middle
that was the idea my first piece i ever
grabbed was
my capillary i got this from treasures
up inside of chicago
and yeah first i got a watch from them
this was right i thought i signed a deal
not even
uh what i thought i signed the new i
went and bought a watch for them and
then
right after that i put in an order for
this and the first time i was able to
wear it i picked it up they had big gym
in chicago it's a big show
that they have in chicago and that was
the first time that i wore that chain
cost me about 40
000 with the tennis
[Music]
this change i got from waffy it costed
me about like
a hundred fifteen thousand dollars man
it's a 3d cube and it's sitting on the
3d cube
i think it's about six inches long waffy
responsible for at least about four or
five hundred thousand
dollars worth of the jury that i got i
go to him a lot that's like the top july
rock with he always gonna
give you a play on the pricing so i'm
definitely locked in with him
the first piece he made for me was the
memorial piece and we went on from there
this piece i got made from waffy too
it's my record label pendant
it's a performance picture of me in the
middle it's supposed to be like the nba
logo
where i got the white gold on one side
and the
rose gold on the other side they got the
baguette cuts on the outline
and then down the sides of the pendant
it says only dream's achieved
that's what my label is only dreams
achieved i'm a basketball fanatic so
even if you listen to my music like i
always got a basketball reference
that was just like a creative thing that
i came up with and i sent that
idea to a graphic designer and he sent
me back the logo
and i've been rocking out with it i got
these rings i just got three rings from
icebox
they supposed to symbolize my albums
being like championships for me
my first two albums the guy legend and i
got
the goat these both went platinum
already and my new album
that i got coming out was called hall of
fame so and they rushed it after this
interview i had my sister fly out with
him
this really actually my first time
having them all and seeing them in
person
they feel like a good fit my hall of
fame window i feel like it got to be
fitted better but
i definitely rock with them i definitely
appreciate icebox for russians for me
too
[Music]
with my watch collection like i just
really try to get
everything or every different watch
brand that i don't have
so slowly but surely i'll probably end
up having every single
popular watch ever manufactured so i
really started off with a rolex that was
my first watch that i ever got but i
ended up trading that in and i went
about this watch from waffy with my
1300 chain and he put like big pointers
down the side of it it's like a custom
101 watch
and yeah i think this is a presidential
rolex
before i got to that watch i went and
bought this i was searching for this
watch for a long time
it's like every time that i would check
back in on the prices for
a jeweler give me a new number at first
this watch was probably about forty
thousand dollars when i first looked
into it
and when i purchased it i purchased it
for about ninety thousand dollars and
now it's
probably up another 30k but that's
really covert prices
because they low on inventory for a lot
of stuff so it's hard to get
and also the price of gold is going up
and then yeah i got this cartier
i got it from icebox just wanting to get
a watch that i know
i never really had so and i like the big
faces like almost
richard milley style and then i went and
grabbed this
i got this watch from a ralph lauren
store and i had waffy going busting down
because you know my name
polo so this is never going to increase
in value this is literally just for me
and the patek philippe that i got on i
got when my album dropped
yeah i'm definitely one of the first
people to ever put my face inside of my
watch i got my album cover put inside my
watch with
all of my loved ones in there who passed
away and i got the same inside of this
memorial piece
so it's like a four cent
uh future chain that i'm getting i'm
gonna get a new uh record label chain
i'm gonna get oda adjusted three letters
get a hard-ass design for that
aside from that i'm gonna definitely get
a hall of fame chain
for my album i always get a change made
for my album i just don't know when yeah
because i've been buying so much and
that's just sometimes i've been meaning
to break
thank you guys for checking out all my
ice man i'll see y'all next time